- This is framed around
80% of football players
but the reality is it's
also 80% of startups,
it's 80% of trust fund babies,
it's 80% of individuals or situations
where a lot of money's come in
and the reality is the person
is not thinking long term,
is not making strategic decisions
in the short term for the long term,
is worried about optics on the outside.
Flossing is no different
than buying a huge office
for a startup.
It's all perceptions to
check the box of insecurities
then manifested in bad short term behavior
at the expense of long term upside.
I hope you enjoy this
and whether you're a
football player or an athlete
or just somebody who's in a situation
where some dollars are
coming in in the short term
but you're vulnerable to the macro,
whether that's injuries
or the global economy,
be thoughtful after
you're done watching this.
(upbeat music)
The level of taking for
granted what you're sitting on
is extraordinary.
The amount of business men
and women, thought leaders,
people that this place is religion to,
are willing to have a
conversation with you,
look at you totally different today
than they will in three or four years.
To me, the leverage of
being a ball player here
like you are now
and every classmate wants to talk to you,
wants to have some sort of relationship,
then I know that 90% of them
are gonna have more leverage than you
in five or seven years.
I just want you to strike.
Yo, we are going to build a
very disruptive sports agency.
We are gonna make more money off the field
for these athletes than
anybody has ever done
because we'll do small deals,
we won't hustle,
we're not just gonna rely
on Puma, Reebok, Nike,
Under Armour and Panini sports cards.
So it's gonna come to us in waves
but that's how, just
personal relationships.
The ROI of things like
college are the people.
People are the game in life.
That's how life actually plays out.
(upbeat music)
I'm all about you playing Fortnite,
look, I'm all about you
talking to those girls on DM.
I'm all about that, I mean it
but allocating, allocating
time to leverage your moment,
to understand what you're
actually sitting on
with the leverage of the brand
that this has been created,
that's something you can learn here
that you can use for
the rest of your life.
I think that there's,
there's a couple ways to
think about making money.
You can make money as an
entrepreneur and business person
which I've done.
You build and you sell
stuff, you start a business.
There's also you've got enough,
just enough level of fame
to be you and make money.
What does that mean?
That means,
and we can help you
with this a little bit,
can you get paid $2,000 to
give a talk in the northwest?
That's where your brand most lives, right?
Heck, I think Jaylynn might
end up making more money
post his playing career
giving public speeches
of being the first guy
that signed with this
new formed Vayner thing,
we're really gonna change it.
And listen, I got more money
on a shoe deal from K-Swiss
than 99% of the players in the NFL.
You know what's tough is like,
what we don't talk about now
is post that last collective
bargaining agreement
rookies aren't making that much money.
Like you're making money,
when you've got nothing,
hundreds of thousands is real
but you guys, everybody knows the stories,
you start getting those 47 phone calls,
Jaylynn Reeves Maben,
lineback from Tennessee,
kid that we represent now at VaynerSports,
fourth round pick,
his phone blows up when he
gets drafted, fourth round.
You know what the economics
of that now look like?
You know what's tough?
You get to the league
and you think that was it, right,
you know it's not but
you still think it is
'cause now high school of
course, you get to this,
you've got the fucking bullshit NCAA,
so you still not making bank,
now you're in the league right
and you feel like at
some level you've made it
but the truth is the money's not there
until that second contract
that can really get you
to be like phew, right?
So the key is actually locking down
in those first couple years
and really being smart with those,
making those right investments,
hopefully you stay healthy
and get to that second deal.
(upbeat music)
Same with entrepreneurs.
It's why I feel bad for athletes.
- [Male] Right, right, right.
- I used to think it was the best.
Like James Harden's gonna
be done at 36 forever,
the thing he was meant to do.
Nick, I think one of the
things that you can do
is start becoming a
practitioner and an executer
in the place that you're passionate about.
You're gonna kick out of
football at some point
and what's gonna happen
is you're gonna want
to go and do something.
Being good at that actually matters.
It's about not only networking,
having relationships,
but then you've got to be able
to bring tangible skills to the table.
And so that's what I would be doing Nick.
Now getting deeper into your studies
on the thing that you
want to be doing post-NFL.
(upbeat music)